that's pretty good this is B that's all
it says right only line that's this is
hiccup citizens of the reject Nation
it's me Tera Erikson alongside
Gregory Alba God he doesn't join in on
the rap game you guys heard the rap in
my voice he was supposed to continue it
it in the voice with all this noise o
that's good we're going to watch How to
Train dragon three three with Terra and
Gregory yeah man flying through the sky
feeling so free oh my hair wow what do I
see the Night
Fury so good don't forget to leave a
like for that what you got to type in
the comments and say how cool we are and
don't forget to ring the
bell ring the bell also the real reject
has their own apparel line are you going
to tell them about it Gregory let me
tell them about it Terry okay look at
here's one design here's another design
here's another design I'm wearing one of
the designs it's a soda got another
Design coming up right now I brought my
sister on board to become the head
artist for us and we've already sold a
lot and it is one of the absolute best
ways to support the channel to show your
love as a citizen of the reject
still stuck in the fact that I haven't
been gifted any real rejects apparel go
ahead and leave it in the comments you
can tell them 2023 you ear tshirt you
earn your keep I need a t-shirt then I
would show up wearing the apparel shout
out the patreon don't forget we call you
super sexy super sexy when you join on
patreon.com you get to sync up with your
full copy watch with me and GRE are you
ready cuz I feel like I'm ready I'm
ready man today my emotions are stoic
they're watch wild mine are wild yours
are stoic which is down here mine
is Hey where's my this is
Bine oh who are these jerks
meanies ha yeah oh yeah this is hiccup
what are
you oh hell yeah oh
yep oh he looks
taller he can handle some
Flames ooh cool you're a demon I'm not a
demon see just a guy he's so much older
you walked through fire dragon scales
your human legs are last
in thinkig that that's a good entrance
oh my goodness behold along with his
sister who insisted on coming that's my
intro oh she looks older to me find a
sitter demons everywhere it's the end of
the world
ouchie we're going to get you out of
here oh my God they're like Dragon
rights activists
now get the rescues out of here get that
night
uh-oh
step aside let me handle the tough guy
stuff it's a cool
warer that's two for
me look
out sorry wow it's still one shot yeah
it's
awesome good hustle
boys toothless time to go what do you
sense my boy what is it
I saw that on on the cover yeah but I
didn't want to ruin that for
you you always have my back butt they
have to go back for the Night Fury baby
my cat's ta and copper are a black cat
and a white cat but they're not lovers
I'm assuming they're lovers in this one
well felt feminine this is Burke this is
Burke home away from home so many
dragons now dream
so settle in and light your worries melt
away the cuisine's
fiery do people actually get a like
visit here now I guess we my friend have
dragons lots and lots of dragons are you
sure it's not oh that's cool
overpopulated I mean it looks like it
like it's busting at the seams hiccup's
mom any notes on my bone crushing
assault or was it pretty much much
perfect still doesn't know her name it
was Indescribable and please call me
Valk it has been a year first name bis
it's only been a year that was pretty
sloppy perhaps you all rely a little bit
too much on your dragons and not enough
on one another then what's the point of
having dragons you found a new
friend oh no oh no uh-oh yeah I'm
surprised B is still standing there's
like right when we came in with one shot
there's a building fing down CU there
was too many on there and now here we go
oh boy yeah you guys are going to have
to find a new home maybe the one that
mom had before hang up those Saddles and
get married are they still not like I
guess
not with you wearing the pants there's
still hope wow not awkward at all
a don't be like that I thought they were
already buried down two more Trapper
barges spotted in the straight so we go
after them one day you're going to pick
a fight you can't win oh yes oh that's
that's some
foreshadow I wonder who the villain will
be this time uhoh whoa this looks like
the dead marshes out of the two towers
yeah oh oh last time the villain was
really large and this one's like
gaunt yeah is this my dear
warlord how go your plans to conquer the
world that's definitely a villain stoic
boy he in his peace loving Dragon Riders
continue to raid our ships and steal our
dragons but I'm in the business of
killing dragons dragon slayer why bother
me because the flock is protected by a
night
Fury a crap oh now it so we'll pay you
to capture him and bring the flock to us
we even have your favorite
bait oh
no a
female is that a a white Fury yeah it
looks just like cuz that's why I was
like why are they oh it must be a like
is it because it's white is it going to
did he just kill is this the first time
we've seen a human actually kill a
dragon young Chief will bring me the
Night Fury they don't have a leader just
a boy okay I was going to say is because
it's white are they going to call day
Fury and then he killed that Dragon just
straight up and I it's my job as Chief
to protect us zup and one day when
you're all growing up that job will be
passed on to you oh this is going to be
a full circle Beyond beond the sunset
lies the home of the Dragons ships that
sailed too close to it only to drop off
the edge of the world that's where we
got to go to Tales of a great waterfall
and Dragons guarding the entrance to a
hidden world it's going to look
beautiful one day I'll find the hidden
world and seal it up so that people and
Dragons will fight no
more no do you know what's going to
happen they're going to have to send the
Dragon
right oh God no somebody's going to seal
it up no I don't know what's going to
happen yeah
have they'll have to cuz it's
overcrowded or to keep them safe yeah
they need a Haven or they could be like
here's the area where you could go visit
over the waterfall and you come visit
Burke
anytime getting pretty good at gliding
on your own bud no no oh my God I hate
it I mean good for you toothless that's
so sad but necessary a secret land at
the edge of the world where dragons live
totally Out Of Reach be the answer to
all of our problems by moving the
dragons there all of us oh and abandon
our home of Seven Generations yeah you
need enough room the home your father
left you to protect I mean it's just a
rock the reality honey is that houses
are falling down left and right
oh
toothless he's going to go
fly oh no don't get lost or hurt please
he's off on his
own is that the white day Fury the white
the white day
Fury oh no is it a trap I mean more than
likely right yeah I just don't like it
but it's so glistening looks like a
Listerine commercial she's so sparkly
she has
glitter so
[Music]
cute all right let's see how dragons
Court each
other oh she's so scared should be
scared but a man just comes up to you
like
that oh my
God love the reflections in their
eyes no no what's that what was that
sound oh my go H
hiccup oh yeah no no need to kill
us no don't go back to the mean
people a poor
guy
who what does she just like Snap flash
into another dimension I love a lot of
these tracking shots bright a light
Fury yeah your is better probably yeah
could have gone there we didn't get
there night yeah no well a
night what's gotten into you what is all
this slobbering and panting you know
exactly what's going on toothless has a
girlfriend but it's so sweet look
oh my God it's the cutest thing I
love all right let's head back to the
woods and see if we can find her too
much practice on your arm it'll be hard
but you have my word and until I break
that word I won't it must be like a
really long game of baiting over there
what is that in the time here you see
some shiny thing in the woods tried to
attack and then it got got away it got
away nope it's a trap it's going to
happen again huh it's definitely TR no
don't move a muscle
hey
wow oh he's smart that was smart yeah I
know this handiwork grimmel the grizzly
the smartest Dragon Hunter I ever met
next to me of course sure Mar my words
he'll be back they we be waiting for him
you should listen to that guy you're
being too confident Man Too confident
take a page out of Terror and Greg lack
of confidence goes a long
way is he
there I assume this has to be yeah
Grimsley right yeah there he is this is
quite good
oh that is
impressive toothless no your father knew
of me now there was a chief making it
his mission to destroy the beasts so
that you could grow up in a better world
he changed his mind look where that got
him cold man that's cold I am the Night
Fury killer I've hunted every last one
but yours you are going to give me that
dragon or I will I will never give him
up we know it oh he's not there oh
hiccup you one up did we get
him
now oh cool you think you can come into
my home and threaten my dragon this is
Burke and we have defended our way of
life from far worse than
you or was this part of his plan I'm
afraid you're mistaken youve never seen
anything like me oh what please
no
God as look
out oh it's like a scorpion
dragon is that
acid it looks like spooky G
uh ooh that is horrifying have my dragon
ready when I return or I will destroy
everything you
love hey the dragons are already
destroying Burke for you buddy yeah you
guys got to make it to the end of the
waterfall and do it quick we're Vikings
we don't run from a fight he's a
predator single-minded and patient he
won't stop until he gets what he wants
I'm with Eris we have to take this
threat
seriously jealous I don't see a way of
staying here any longer right you got to
get out if we want to live in peace with
our dragons we need a better plan I'm
saying we have to disappear take the
dragons to a place where no one will
find them this is a crazy proposal my
father he made notes and maps in search
of the ancestral home of all dragons I
know this is our home my father left me
to protect it home is the people I say
Burke is wherever we go I'm with him who
else
yes okay oh all right just transition to
okay the Night Fury escaped you again I
encouraged it they've abandoned their
only defensible position yeah exactly
the Night Fury is distracted I
introduced him to your female the light
Fury scent he won't be able to leave it
okay she's following
us this is all part of this plan
whoa hold up tothless oh I hate the fact
that they're just being just totally
used look who it
is no no
no
fin
[Music]
okay he's getting in the way of us oh my
God he's conflicted my God he really
is so great not a
word
[Music]
Furies can't survive in the cold so they
haven't gone North they're trying to put
distance between themselves and enemies
to the east and south oh my God this guy
is a tactician gang I I said make Camp
not build a new Village died and made
you
Chief what
dude all right you could stay until
Toothless and I find the hidden world I
should head back to make sure we weren't
followed I'll go with you you're far too
important here
yeah this plan though I wish it were
possible I fear it can't last hiccup I
mean you know I tried to do the same for
years yeah very realistic Toth no it's
too
early light fury it's stalking around
with her scent whoa what camouflage oh
my gosh that's
cool
oh my
God I do love the visual storytelling of
just them like how it's you can't have
dialogue with it you know you just got
to watch the body language of them
falling in
love are you good oh
no
no hey hey she did it she's so much more
confident than
[Music]
him that's so
cute he's literally being a wingman
for
come on hiccup woo
[Music]
her oh my
God maybe just be
herself
oh my
[Music]
God he's losing it just you're trying
too hard man oh I love
it like a bat that's
[Applause]
cool
look
[Music]
sick of your
advice oh that's
her oh she's like
pink damn this environment is gorgeous
yeah a she hates him so much this poor
guy whenever he flies it's so sad he
needs to be able to fly with
her oh he's going to come with like a
permanent solution I bet I'm impressed
embracing change I am proud of you he's
my best bud I want him to be happy and
besides it's just until he brings her
back he's displaying dad
qualities bring her home my son down at
the
latest now save it for your girlfriend
go on get out of
here it's
okay this is going to have such a sad
ending man you just totally feel it want
it I really don't want
it
[Music]
oh what a terrifying thing to ride solo
over
[Music]
uhoh
no yeah good job
[Applause]
Dragon oh great
shot wow that would be so close in the
theater as well
yeah was it a storm
no it's the sound of her when
she's oh whatever that's
called there she is
okay hey check me out so cute got some
[Music]
upgrades now storytelling really takes
advantage of its animated
medium oh my god oh see that is a storm
Gregory sorry you were 100% right wow
this is not romantic guys what are you
doing yeah like is something bad gonna
can he get it might have been that too
I'm just saying okay like he can't get
hurt cuz he has metal on him right like
electrocuted with its tail uh whatever
he'll be fine they'll be
[Music]
fine he just took a
[Applause]
shot oh W he locked his potential every
every movie he's
upgraded that's such a cute shot I can't
stand it oh my God he gave her the
lick oh so
[Music]
beautiful W waterfall yes is there going
to be more dragons over
there whoa great sound design good
transition too there wow what if the
tail broke would you relax he's probably
having the time of his life how would I
know she never comes around and when she
does she's always rushing
off she's so wild and skittish I'm just
going to say it I don't trust
her this is great grand is tracking us
he has 100 ships with enough cages for
all of our dragons we have to take him
out of the mix by going there to capture
him I'm with him who
else it's not going to work every
time oh he creates it
himself
okay oh remember stealth missions don't
always start off stealthy but she saw
him so he's lurring yeah he knows
exactly what's going to happen he's
always one step ahead yep yep
okay that flame will draw a lot of
attention to you well he already knows
they're there so just doesn't really
matter what is
that okay wow you just locked yourselves
in first rule of the hunt separate the
prey from its pack you've just removed
yourselves from the equation a this
gloating bastard but I was a boy and I
Came Upon a Night Fury I killed it where
it slipped this is why he's the worst
this could have been the path hiccup
went down but you have dragons of your
own pre like drugged into obedience with
their own Venom oh drugged not even you
precious Alpha could control them oh
that is so Sinister allow me to
demonstrate take
[Applause]
cover
oh split
up w who it melts oh wow okay but it's
gak and then it's fire it is like some
type of acid fire some fiery gak I don't
even know I wonder if light and night if
they put their power together they can
override
[Applause]
it well also if they could just take
those serums out of their foreheads they
might but they've been injected with it
right he's constantly injecting his
dragons with their own serum to make
them
amenable and I'm like well if he if they
could pull those out then the dragons
wouldn't be
right jumper all
right oh yes good job awesome he takes
that stupid baby
everywhere what is she doing what just
happened uh where is ruffnut we we left
her behind how could you not notice she
was missing you ride a two-headed dragon
I feel like how ruffnut is every day
dumb we will get ruffnut back don't
worry if they're stuck with rough nut
I'm more worried about them I know what
you're thinking you've never had a
prisoner this
hot all the boys love me except Aon who
totally lost his chance that ship has
sailed boy sorry and hicup is
practically married to that roundhead
astd don't give information can't we
just feed her to your dragons hey what
do you have to eat around here I'm
allergic to fish you should know that
that's all they have at that stupid new
island oh yeah here we go we know it is
B to come out most annoying creature
ever to cross my path a I got to let her
go and then follow her stress is not
good for
you that's really annoying long losers
it's like just it's a little too stupid
for me yeah where where is she heading
she's tracking something aren you
girl there's nothing but miles and miles
of what oh is it the waterfall
okay whoa oh wow I didn't realize it was
shaped like that yeah that's not that's
like a whole different
thing oh
wow oh no this is beautiful where would
the humans
stay w it's even more
Avatar did Avatar rip this wao wow oh my
gosh oh how
gorgeous
who baby dragons are these all baby
dragons maybe and they're lighting up
like there's like energy connection
between
them oh how gorgeous oh this would have
been so cool to seen the theaters w
oh what what oh my goodness I mean it
can't be that far from where their Camp
to now so they can visit whoa oh my
goodness it is a whole world amazing and
that's the world that they need because
how look how huge it
is yeah of things it's crystals L
mushrooms are they
playing you'll spook
them
are they like king and queen of it like
well they're like bouncing off of this
like Crystal's energy or
what oh wow he's even still the alpha to
all of them I mean night furies seem to
be the most dominant
ones now that's a King serving his
Queen
oh
a they are so cute together I love them
so
much is like Dragon culture so
pretty we going to have to let toothless
go buddy it's so sad but I'm just glad
he's like happy at least we should go
screw that teror oh no I know but like
oh no no no is it the Bad
Dragon is it the same Bad Dragon I I
mean it has to be right or is just one
of the a lives there that feels
threatened scal this is crazy go whoa
whoa
whoa oh is it cuz like still in this in
this world like I'm sorry but I humans
are bad right like they haven't been are
you going to get us a new mom I don't
want another your mom was the only woman
for me she was the love of my life but
with love comes loss son it's part of
the deal there's no greater gift than
love it's a real doozy this is why
whenever I get a pet like it's going to
hurt you I have to say body one
day it's okay but you belong there with
her what already we'll find a way to
man is she there she follow a a she
loves
him
you might not have to say goodbye after
all but is that still the right choice
no they're going to have to go back to
the world eventually how did you escape
I annoyed them till they let me go wait
wait Grim will let you go so dumb oh
you're catching on now get ready for
battle K become the most hated character
this whole trilogy
toothless no I don't
it gives me
anxiety
no oh my God I hate
it no no no
no dang
it no you got to be kidding me this is
so
[Music]
cruel
[Applause]
oh he's saying stay back because he
doesn't want her to die oh don't feel
too badly you tried your best this guy
is such an Nothing Without Your
Dragon that's not
true oh they're all going I feel like
the same screw-up I was before I met
toothless but I was the first to believe
in you you were the bravest knucklehead
I know you are romantic toothless didn't
give you that hiccup he just made it
easier and now it's going to be a lot
harder what are you going to do about it
probably something
stupid wow it's coming full circle every
good Trilogy calls back to the first one
how are we going to get our dragons back
without dragons trust me okay how
though can you explain are we going to
take a ship are we going to build a ship
are they're all going to get suits oh
yeah maybe jump off the cliff
you try to keep up all right wa that
would be so
scary oh the wing suit should have
dragon scale on it yes I would love to
see him knocked out multiple
times oh
okay yeah yeah yes strategize eyes I
love how toothless has also really
become a leader as well like they really
grew together that's so beautiful oh
what a cool
shot yeah what are you waiting for get
in
there no no no no no yeah you blow him
up toothless good job no no no uh-oh oh
no oh oh what
no at least landed
there let's just
see somebody kill him already I hate
him oh yeah take this serum out of there
oh God no no no no no
no yes over two coming through surprise
sorry about that come on oh working as a
team sorry we're late for the party
you're right on time what are you going
to do it's fun that they they brought
fire wow this is some epic
action
wow another they a cage that's great
they brought the fire to Burke and now
Burke brought the fire to them where is
he leading him this is bugging me
oh because Night Fury can't survive in
the cold yeah oh
no what damn
we all come on take the serum out of is
this a do the thing do the thing yeah
what are you doing can he handle it oh
he's got the dragon scale he can handle
it no it
boom did he just kill his other dragons
uh yeah did hiccup
survive
waa no oh no oh oh God such oh my God oh
my God fighting over a dragon that's
your plan she'll go get him take the
thing off go get
him save him
Let Go like Let Him let go
[Music]
yeah oh he has his suit uh
okay uh please don't let this be a thing
where he saves his child but he
dies ah no I can't handle it what no no
no no no no
[Music]
no a
sa oh she she's come around cuz I was
going lose
it I knew you'd come around that's
exactly what I
said I really thought toothless might
come
in man what a like roller Co through the
last like 15 minutes has
jeez
[Applause]
a this movies try not to cry challenges
Jesus
Christ's hey good morning
bud here you
go he's all
yours you on your best behavior in front
of
[Music]
people oh does he want to
go to the world he misses
it
you're right bud it's time oh I was so
busy fighting for a world that I wanted
I didn't think about what you
needed you've looked after us for long
enough time to look after
yourselves
all you got to say about all the
dragons oh Stormfly my good
girl so long you big ugly beast I miss
you oh Cloud
Jumper oh man that must be the hardest
for her go on butt lead them to the
Hidden
World you'll be safe
there our world doesn't deserve
you
yet go How to Train Your Dragon
for make it
happen this is so sad hey she's back for
CIA
like the first one like was a father son
story and this is like a father son
story that's really well done Trilogy
man that's really well
done oh man this this going to be a
hiccup like 45 or something this going
to be like super old really old
at Christmas time I'm I'm done crying
this guy ages so
fast oh they're getting married
oh
Arn W this looks just like my
wedding for the chief and chief
Das come cry to my full thick beard oh
my God we we have tissues here for
tera's ears let's explain after what I
mean by that I never have tissues your
fire this
for I pad out there were dragons when I
was a
boy oh there were great Grim Sky dragons
oh my God oh my God little brown Scuttle
dragons had hunted down the mice and
rats and well organized packs two sea
dragons some say they crawled back into
the sea others say they were nothing but
folktales to begin with
a look at that that was
[Music]
great
hey hey there bud
remember you sniff it it's
okay
yeah hey I am glad to see you
too he's not going to eat your
father oh my
God that's
it
a eat them toothless then smash the
black oh my God it's so cute wow you're
going to make your kid throw
up oh
asard oh my gosh it's so cute I thought
asra would be riding
her oh IIT know she got her Dragon back
yeah Legend says that when the ground
Quicks or lava spews from the earth it's
the dragons letting us know they're
still here or Earth
deteriorating and we'll guard the secret
until the time comes when dragons can
return in peace
nice yay wow they should do How to Train
Your Dragon in
2025 put it in modern day movie it's so
good I can't even stand how good it is
that's a
really like well
structured
Trilogy it perfectly wraps up the story
of a Trilogy and it it complement and
mirrors and revisits really well
done oh
man when he goes with his family and he
sees them oh man I can't be doing that
that's too cute the the very beginning
of the
movie is telling
you right at front hey they going to go
sear like at the very beginning and I
was like oh no and I was just trying to
prepare myself for it and and and I felt
my my soul like go like you know when
sometimes in real life if I have to say
bye to someone I'm like you shut down
down I found myself shutting down and I
got to be I'm like no you got to let's
learn from this movie learn to say
goodbye it's you learn to let go man
it's the last one connect with it by the
way uh our reviews go up on like apple
and Spotify and stuff so if you're
listening there please uh leave a like
or no not leave a like rate it you know
do that thing helps us out there helps
us out help us out that's our our
introduction we just throw you into the
muck of it no introduction on the
reviews there we just watched out of
trainer Dragon 3 there's our
introduction uh okay yeah we have
tissues here I'm never yeah I'm still oh
you guys just saw if you're watching the
video I just took the tissues out of my
ear because Greg puts the volume up to
like
2550 million DB and it hurts my ear so I
put tissues in there to even it out a
little bit for me I'm a weird viewer if
I'm watching a comedy I don't like sub
subtitles but if I don't if it's not a
cuz I'm like it's going to ruin the joke
if I'm watching a comedy right but if
it's a drama if it's drama or whatever
other genre you'll have it I I I have
subtitles because my mind's like I don't
know what they're saying like I just I
can't register so I usually prefer with
subtitles um and then when we're re
doing these reactions uh you know
sometimes people think we miss when
we're talking I'm like no we actually
don't because the volume's so loud right
and I I like to be absorbed into the
movie the movie yeah I I love that
experience but it really when he's
absorbed it's I'm literally like
unfortunately I can't control tera's Vol
like we share the same volume level so
to compensate I left out a box of
tissues for her her and she puts tissues
in her ears and it is not one of those
things where we were like prepare to cry
grab no it's just it's only if I'm here
he leaves the tissues out so I can put
him in my ear and luckily well there we
go this movie three was not as torturous
for me thank you so much like two I went
through a lot more torture and obviously
I told you it was a like a perfect movie
this one I love and adore like each one
to me is I'm like this is a perfect
Trilogy like what it's so freaking good
but this one I was not as tormented as
much I still was a a little bit
but not not as much which thank you for
that yeah people prepared us saying most
people said it wasn't as good and and I
will I will meet you I will meet people
there uh I appreciated that because uh
have you seen the Kung Fu Panda movies
no yes uh maybe I don't know I have I
did ride the ride when it existed at
Universal Studios which is not a ride
it's like a theater so I feel like maybe
I don't know I'm not a big fan of that I
don't know uh so people said the same
thing about that which is DreamWorks cuz
like one's great two's amazing and then
three is a dip it's still good okay and
so I was kind of expecting sort of a
situation like that based off of what I
saw a couple of common say yeah and I
started to feel that in in the first
half of this movie like okay this is
this the first two
transcended um you know kids animation
movie like it just they just especially
the second one was just like this is a
cinematic experience you know and I'm
not even aware I'm watching an animated
movie targeted for children uh you know
and this one felt more like that uh uh
significantly more like it felt a lot
more the acte structure kind of or like
do you mean
execution the dialogue the back and
forth a lot of it felt like oh I was
more aware I'm watching like a kid's
anime animated movie this time but I
mean it's not that's not too it's like
it's only a put down in comparison to
the first two as a standalone film that
that doesn't work as a standalone like
you need the other two to watch this but
just an isolation like no it's still
above average of your of your typical
animated kids movie and in the last like
20 30 minutes of this I'm like okay this
is the How to Train Your Dragon movie
that um from the other that that matches
the par of the other two you know I
agree yeah oh my God when he especially
when he I mean the the part with the
villain in this one is a little bit
shorter of like he's around but you're
right we cut back to like uh you know um
night uh Toothless and the girl like
flying around in their relationship but
I was constantly in my stomach going
like wait isn't he using the light Fury
to get to them like I thought something
was going to continually happen while
they were falling for each other
and it didn't until way later than I
thought I mean he was but he was it
wasn't like mind controlling her yeah
that's what I thought too like is he
look she on it in some way without
knowing you know right and like she
wasn't so cool but it it made it less
the the villain esque part less like
palpable I guess yeah um so that it is
more I guess kid-friendly when we do cut
back to him he's there he's making up a
plan we it's kind of an underlying thing
where we like we know he's going to pop
up but it wasn't as intense as two where
I was like I I think I screamed like
murder that guy a million times and I
didn't I didn't have that yes I wanted
the villain to die but it was not as
strong as in the last one yeah I think
the I would say like the skeleton and
the bones of this one is really really
good it's the it's the overall execution
like pacing wise uh tonal wise and and
like and like even with the villain too
like it it there's stuff that's like
it's goofy you know stuff that's a
little bit more goofy still good though
I'm not just saying that's be nice it's
still good still above average I love
the scenes with with light Fury and when
they're
glowing yeah when when they're bonding
and with night and light Fury yeah and
uh when they're when they're just you
know falling in love with each other
like that to me was oh this is true
animated movie right here where there's
no dialogue we have to just connect with
their expressions and their body
language and their eyes and I I love how
they take advantage of that with them
and for a movie about dragons and not
and dragons that can't talk or at least
speak our our our language it was so
cool to just get that experience and we
didn't get that till the third movie and
I thought that was great to provide that
for us yeah and the the themes too of um
love and letting go and just the I'm
really impressed with how they brought
it back with the cuz you know it it
never felt like a fatherson story to me
between Toothless and Hiccup um right
until until here where it's like really
defined because he always says like
you're my best friend yeah and and so I
think even making Toothless in the
likeness of a cat even makes it more
like that you know um the time of
filming this I'm not been public about
it at all I've had some crazy cat
experiences with my my babies started
right I'm working off an hour and 40
minutes of sleep right now I was at the
ER this morning with my cat um and then
there was a whole Fiasco of things over
the last few days and I'm but but
they're okay none of them are dead
they're okay there was a situation A few
days ago where it was it was looking
really terrifying um so but but like
I've been telling the people who I have
told to who like don't have cats like
look I don't have children so I'm not
going to be one of those guys who says
they're they're my children I'll say
they're I say they're my children
they're the but I'm talking to someone
with kids I'm like they're the closest
thing I have have to a child you know
and and at the end of the day they're
still family to me and so it's been a
really hard few days so this especially
right now really hit home and and I
think to draw the paral because you know
you'll see that with like man's best
friend is dog and then here you don't
really say that with your cats uh right
and but uh here or at least the
expression is not as prominent and this
to bring it to a fatherson story between
Hiccup and Toothless and then for hiccup
to be learning the lessons from stoic
and like the flashbacks were
appropriately done uh yeah no I I still
overall I was like oh I like this one
and then by the end I was like no I
would say I loved it yeah you know oh
yeah I mean him him learning to like I
guess yeah like really his lesson in
learning to let go Al those he hiccup
has had to let go of a lot of things you
know his dad prior to this but him like
on another level of um just having it be
his decision and seeing like toothless
grow up and he has to go off on his own
um yeah it it was nice and it was nice
to see him make the the tale for him of
like well you know he's he's my buddy
and I want to do what's best for him um
uh so that he could go fly and with his
girlfriend and stuff and uh
[Laughter]
I I feel like um towards the end of him
and the relationship with astred I'm
like it could have really only not only
gotten there but was really only going
to get there I think until there was
more space to allow their relationship
because before it was like a lot of just
um Hiccup and Toothless right and
asterids on the outskirts and they have
dragons and they go and they fight them
and they fly around and now their life
is more like like well we have to live
kind of like like humans do right for a
while and that allowed him to like
really form their relationship cuz
everyone was like get married get
married and she was like we don't really
need to do that it's not like she was
ever pressuring him but the space I
think and allowed the opportunity for
them to start a family and this space
allowed uh tooth was the same I mean he
needed space in his own world the
Dragons Were ripping their world down
they weren't going to punish them for it
cuz they're good people and yeah I think
like him saying the world of humans and
Dragons is not ready to coexist yet he
did say that in this movie so it's like
they tied it up in a nice little pretty
bow um and I think the yet we did see
towards the very end of that he does get
to go visit them but I thought like oh
wow are they going to do like a fourth
where there is eventually like maybe a
little bit of a world because it's so
huge in there where they can't all live
together again I don't know I doubt it
um because they tied it up nicely where
the dragons get their world they get
theirs they can go visit say hi to the
family and go back home they should do
it like in the far future like yeah like
a long time from now yeah we're dead and
then the movie comes out yeah no I'm
saying the movie should take place in
the future oh got
it oh yeah well I mean going off what
you're talking about because a big part
of in addition to him letting
go this is hiccup's Journey of
discovering his selfworth you know
like I I didn't even think about that of
until this movie really put a spotlight
on it that there is I mean the saying
the word codependent it's I feel like
there such that's such a negative
connotation to that there is a
dependency that he had on on hi uh on
toothless yeah and but it wasn't like a
toxic thing you know that's that's the
thing about saying codependency it's
such a toxic Association it it wasn't a
toxicity
whatsoever however he did put all of his
worth in in that and he felt like to be
a leader and to be a warrior and to be a
fighter and all it was very much
dependent on night fear on his yeah on
his Night Fury and and the dragons and
everything and like that's what gives
them their power and that's what makes
them special and unique and and this was
about embracing the people but also
taking the lessons learned from them uh
of of the bond of the bonding and even
with the the wing suit stuff and
everything like there he you see him
form into a you're watching him become a
man over the course of these films yeah
up to the final frames of this movie
where he's he's a family man right by
the end of this uh this Trilogy which is
great like this really is his journey
and it's the same thing with toothless
where he's growing up and becoming a
becomes a leader and a and and a and a
family dragon as well it's really cool
it's it's a really well done narrative
like as a Trilogy it's a really solid
narrative for from all three and you
don't really see that with a lot of
trilogies and a lot of times the the the
TR the third one usually sucks or they
don't they try to tie it back to the
first one in a way to to wrap it up at
it feels force or whatever and this one
does it really well where a lot of it
kind of sneaks up on you you know yeah I
agree and like just to touch on the
selfworth thing they made like astred
sort of like the mom was at the head of
IT of going you you have to help him to
see because the second like uh that
hiccup was gone she was like on top of
it which I liked um and I like that you
know asard had to remind him a couple of
times um to really so that he could
really see for himself that he didn't
necessarily need hiccup in order to lead
which was nice yeah um I mean listen I I
give it an eight and a half I mean I I
want to go nine out of 10 I just the
this whole trilogy overall 13 out of 10
yeah 23 out of 10 like I love it all I
agree with you as a as a Trilogy I would
say Bravo I would still rank this I mean
emotionally this is like number two for
me emotion yeah um but as a movie as a
whole it's number two number three
um but I mean number two is is obviously
number one number two put you through
the ringer number two is was just some
other Majestic thing yeah that was and
and I also thought last thing I'll say
is I think the the world exploration of
the the Hidden World we didn't spend too
much time there but I thought that was
smart to kind of keep it something that
is more for Hiccup and and uh they never
gave her Fury we never gave her name
right I don't call her Linda um for
Toothless and Linda mhm for them to have
great name something felt just
Fantastical and mystical and ethereal
and Lind something that is not fully
tangible for Humanity definitely Linda
sure yeah Linda like
definitely yeah very ethereal um the
world not Linda I mean her too yeah got
it I thought he was talking about the
name I mean I I describe most women that
way as an excuse to never have hit on
them oh got it yeah as as like oh yeah
women they're ethereal and and and not
tangible for The Human Experience and do
you call them all lindas I mean yeah
some people say Karen but I think that's
a negative word and Lind Linda's not
nope no it's just just Linda yeah got
it well we on the same bit now we know I
think we're on the same bit yeah I mean
I think we have been the for the last
minute and a half all right so I think I
guess we say goodbye now right can we
shout someone out oh yeah let's do it
okay okay all
right all right all right I I got this
okay we're gonna take it away kid we're
gonna do this a little bit different oh
different I wanted to experiment oh all
right get ready for it experiment
we're going to do this in real
time I have opened up chat
gbt everyone's favorite thing what are
we doing all right pick a name out of
these four Ricardo Martinez all right
Ricardo Martinez all right for Ricardo
Martinez give some uh okay let's give
him some words and let's play a little a
slight Mad Libs game here okay uh an
item oh a lamp a lamp yep okay and then
um an an
adjective oh okay he's
um playful playful okay uh give another
item another item yeah H spaghetti
spaghetti that's an item I was going to
say fork and I I was like no the
spaghetti okay mood
mood uh I I I was going to say like he's
dark but I kind of don't but he's
playful so like doesn't make sense so
maybe let's try it dark okay dark dark
let's go dark let's go uh all right uh
give me a um um an
occupation he's a doctor doctor okay uh
and then uh just anything that comes to
mind confetti confetti
okay confetti y all right I have a
YouTube channel where I need to shout
out my
Patron Ricardo
Martinez create a shout out for me with
these items 40
words making it
special and make sure to include the
words Greg is a really good typer I
would do that and make a lot of mistakes
I did spell include wrong yeah but they
get it all right Ricardo Martinez let's
see how creative this AI really is oh
boy here we go we could have done better
we're gonna have to sit here all right
read it loud and proud big shout out to
our incredible Patron Ricardo Martinez
like a lamp in the dark you light up our
Channel you playful support is the
spaghetti to our sauce that's not bad
doctor of dedication here's some virtual
confetti for you oh and through the
confetti side wow it was it's the Hat
with the stuff coming out oh my god
wow oh yeah that was well done good job
chat is taking over that's I guess
that's better than anything me and
Gregor could have done I was hiring
writers for months to shout out these
patrons just not with me because I'm a
great improviser you know I'm off the
cuff here you are off the cuff but all
the other shout outs Wild Ride hired
Riders when all I needed to do was type
this into chat gbt there's 30 riders in
the closet right now scream sobbing
because they just lost their job pitch
me a plot for How to Train Your Dragon 4
that takes place in TW
2070 50 oo nice when we are both dead
title how to change drag echo of
Tomorrow a postapocalyptic world where
dragons have been forgotten and humanity
is spread out across small isolated
colonies harnessing technology to surv
oh my God it's going way too long that's
too creative stop gener it's it's too
creative there's a stop J anybody oh my
God thank God my God busting heart of NE
city state God I have a producer
mentality I don't want to read that much
no stupid new lines of a plot summary
stupid did not give you money get out
God Chad I I almost I almost I was
almost on their board I got to hire a
rider he almost lost it I guess I'll pay
them fairly you guys can come out of the
closet now he hired you back take them
shackles off you've had the key the
whole time time they're saying they
don't want to come out cuz see the trust
is ruined you know weird it's
ruined what did we just do here the
trust is ruined they were 30 riders in
the closet and you were
like I mean
trust how do I solve this
writer I thought was going to type in
how do I get rid of terara
ericon that would have been good draging
out yeah
[Music]
bye